[Música]
y convoca esta conferencia para
denunciar ante el pueblo soriano y al
mundo entero está en proceso un golpe de
estado
sumó de inmediato la presidencia del
estado prevista en el orden constitución
constitucional y me comprometo a subir
todas las medidas necesarias para
pacificar el país hoy dejo de lado mi
candidatura a la presidencia de bolivia
para cuidar la democracia no es un
sacrificio es un honor porque lo hago
ante el riesgo de que se divide el voto
democrático entre varios candidatos y
que a consecuencia de esa división el
más acabe ganando la elección más
y si vas a hacer una vuelta provocar
convulsión suspenso lesiones y no
todo apunta a que el movimiento al
socialismo va a tener una mayoría en la
asamblea legislativa plurinacional y eso
no es un capricho sino es decisión del
pueblo boliviano una vez más estamos
convencidos que las bolivianas y
bolivianos están cansados de que el más
que es el protagonista central de la
violencia en el caos el 21 en febrero
por la burla al voto y el 20 de octubre
en función de la persistencia de morales
de ser el presidente eterno de bolivia
lo importante de estos datos que nos
muestran 10% de indecisos que son los
que van a migrar hacia un lado por la
tendencia que yo observo y me animaría a
decir que esos votos no necesariamente
van a ir en el porcentaje que tiene hoy
los candidatos tenemos graves deterioros
económicos tenemos graves deterioros
sociales este tenemos serios problemas
institucionales en la situación
económica por lo tanto es bastante
delicada y es la primera recesión que
tenemos después de los años 80 pero ya
no tienen pues argumentó un programa
político con visión país esto se venía
venir porque haya sido formada en
noviembre transitoria no candidato y los
asesores van sumando sumando y el pueblo
también es consciente de que selección
se juega mucho el futuro del país
que muchos de los ciudadanos muchos de
las provincias ya no quieren saber más
del más así directamente están cansados
con tantas situaciones anómalas que se
han realizado en los 14 años de gobierno
[Música]